they say hey luke we got this idea we
want you to jump without a parachute
and i laughed i got a wife and a son and
i want to be here to talk about it you
know
how much of this has to do with math how
much is science how much is
psychological how much is preparation
how much is the right team
i mean how do you go about preparing for
something like this i think if you don't
have all those things i'm not here
talking to you today i think you have to
stack the deck in your favor and i can
only imagine the conversations are you
sure you want to do this
what were those talks like best talks
that we've ever had in our whole
relationship i've been married 19 years
luke if you had to do it how could you
do it is there a way to do it safe
you don't have the level of fear that
people have what do you fear
yeah i think i got this i think
everything's gonna work out great what
if it doesn't then why would i want to
do something like this
i need to treat this just like another
jump i saw the video i can't even tell
where you're landing
it's tiny it is so small i mean i have
over 20 000 jumps i did about 350 jumps
getting ready for this
you could do something that seems
impossible if you go about it the right
way
really it's a simple physics problem
let's take 220 pounds
going 130 miles an hour
and we need to stop it in about 200 feet
it's insane
[Music]
you know a lot of people consider
themselves thrill seekers i myself
yesterday at my house my dad was in town
my dad is
sitting there to myself and a few of our
friends and he says this jalapeno is
very spicy
can you take it mario takes it he starts
crying i'm like
give me a break i can have this jalapeno
so he gives me the jalapeno
i take it for the first five seconds i
look very brave
15 seconds i'm good 30 seconds i'm good
a minute later i have the milk
bread anything you can think about
because i was crying like a little baby
but if you think you're a thrill seeker
today is the ultimate thrill seeker
because our friend today
luke atkins who is a third generation
jumper he's jumped over nearly 20 000
times he's been a stuntman and i think
iron man
and godzilla and a couple other things
that he's worked on he decided recently
on
uh july 30th of 2016 i believe it's july
30th 2016
to jump with no parachute yes we're
talking about
jumping with no parachute 25 000 feet in
air and land in a net you can't even see
where he was landing but he was able to
pull it off
and there were millions of people to
watch it worldwide on the
social media tv news all this other
stuff so he's with us luke thank you so
much for being a guest on valuetainment
hey thanks for having me i'm stoked to
talk to you so luke i mean
what's the story with wanting to jump
out of a plane with no parachutes i mean
there's better things to do in life you
have a
i think your son's name is logan i think
you're married you're happily
i mean why would you want to jump out of
it 25 feet up without any parachute
sort of funny story uh i got a phone
call that said hey luke will you sign an
nda non-disclosure
agreement and i was like sure i get to
hear about all kinds of cool stuff after
i help felix baumgardner jump from the
edge of space and some other things i've
done
and they give me this thing and i'm sure
i sign it and they get me on the phone
and
they say hey luke we got this idea we
want you to jump without a parachute
and i laughed and uh i told him thanks
but no thanks i got a wife and a son the
exact things you're just saying
i might appear to be this crazy nut ball
but hey man i got a life i need to be
around
i couldn't figure out how to do it i
said thanks but no thanks i'll help you
find somebody i'll find the crazy guy to
do it
then i started thinking in my mind i
kept waking up in the middle of the
night
luke if you had to do it how could you
do it is there a way to do it safe
how can we get there and then i started
coming up and churning calling people
and i called him back and i said hey i
think i'm in let's do it like this
and then what happened next so you say
you're and then
because i'm assuming for a guy i watch
some some of the interviews i watch your
videos
how much of this has to do with math how
much is science how much is
psychological how much is preparation
how much is the right team
i mean how do you go about preparing for
something like this i think if you don't
have all those things i'm not here
talking to you today
i think you have to stack that you have
to stack the deck in your stack the deck
in your favor i just finished working
with david blaine so i got a lot of card
references right now
so uh you stack the deck by you know
come up with the idea this guy came to
me with the idea chris talley and i was
like you know no way
and then i started thinking okay maybe
there's a way to do it let's
let's do it i started calling some stunt
guys and really it's a
simple physics problem let's take 220
pounds
going 130 miles an hour and we need to
stop it
safely in about 200 feet and and how do
we do it
so it's like a kid's science project on
a massive scale that you get to test at
the end
with your life so that part was pretty
cool
yeah by the way how old were you when
you had your first jump uh i was
12 years old when i played my first
tandem skydive and i started jumping by
myself when i was 16.
you at 16 and then the the family it
started off with your grandpa i believe
right
yeah my grandpa got shot down during the
war uh tried to open up the cockpit and
bail out
a crash landed in allied territory in a
field all fine
came back from the war and he always
wondered what it had been like that day
if he could have jumped out
so him and a buddy went to a skydiving
club in the 60s
and made one jump he fell in love with
it um back when instructors had five
jumps
and he got the family business started
and my aunt and uncle took that club and
turned it into a full-blown
family operation that they're running
today now
i remember being in the army i was at
hunter first airborne when you would
hear stories of guys who would go to
become jumpers
back in the 60s there was a risk of
breaking your knee
because the way you were coming down and
technology wasn't as good the equipment
wasn't as good
how much has a you know equipment and
technology advanced over the last
1960s last 50 60 years it's
insane so like back when you jumped and
uh you had to be tough
you just had to be tough there was no
way around it they're coming down around
parachute
it's simply how big is the parachute how
much do you weigh that controls how hard
you hit the ground
then technology changed they came up
with a parafoil design
um which is more like the wing of an
airplane and now we're gliding in with
the materials and the design changes
we're gliding in like a glider airplane
and we flare the parachute out
and we get tiptoe landings nowadays
compared to back then i mean
respect for all those guys in the army
they're still doing it today right yeah
they're still doing it today
all that stuff bailing out and crash
landing in a field and then have to go
to work
i was at 101st airborne even though it
was an airborne unit by the time i got
that they stopped airborne they did air
assault so i only did aerosol
i never had the opportunity to do
airborne but i respected airborne guys
uh like yourself so you know there is
this real cool picture you showed of
your entire family it was like two
cousins
grandpa aunt auntie can you talk i mean
assume the audience is looking at the
picture right now
talk about the picture that you have
with your family jump in yeah so my
family's got you know i grew up on it
when i was 16 it wasn't uh so much of if
you were gonna jump it's wind
you know as soon as i was able we jumped
right in there and i was the older of a
bunch of my cousins
so we all started skydiving as it got
bigger and bigger uh
we started jumping more and more and
most people you know you go play sports
at high school at the end of the day
you'd zip back over
jump back into skydiving pack parachutes
to make more jumps
and it was kind of like a family
business if you worked at a restaurant
you're a busboy
in our family you pack parachutes
it's it's similar to my conversation
with wallanda where he said seventh
generation they walked on wire rope
tight ropes and that's what they did for
a living and that was their family thing
but
do you do you notice a common threat or
a common trend
with people that you run into that are
obsessive
or or love jumping as much as you do is
there a commonality
yeah what i think it does is skydiving
gives you a freedom whether you're a
world-class skydiver
or someone who just made a jump or two
and you have this common bond you find
this small group of people that not very
many people in the world have
experienced what you have
and it kind of draws you in and it kind
of consumes your life and it becomes
part of
you have this bond that not many people
have of jumping out of an airplane
together i mean
in the world you know maybe there's 300
000 people who've made a skydive
including one jump
you know and that's a very small group
of people on the planet that have gotten
to feel what you do
so i think it draws you in and then you
just want to get
some people have a competitive spirit
you want to just go go go and be a
world-class competitor or you just want
the freedom of a guy on the weekend
going out to the y and playing
basketball with their friends it's the
same thing with skydiving just a little
more adventurous
yeah there seems to be a very common
personality
on how they are and you know what what
you know
it's very interesting when i run into
them i have friends that are just die
hard jumpers and they can't get enough
of it
they can't wait for the next one that's
like they're feeding it it's like an
addict
i gotta have my next jump i get i get
that feeling about them but
since your jump that you had you know
the year roger bannister broke the
record a four-minute mile you know they
said oh when he ran broke the
four-minute mile
30-something people did it the following
year ever since you
jumped without a parachute how many
people have done it since you
uh nobody no you see that's what's crazy
about it
that's what's crazy about this record
luke i mean i know for you
you know you're the person that did it
we're the audience okay so there's
there's 7.7 billion people in the world
a lot of people can
can say they climb mount everest a lot
of people can say they did a lot of diff
there's many billionaires in the world
there are four trillion dollar companies
in the world there's only
one let me say the proper adjective
courageous
guy there's only one
courageous guy that jumped out of a
plane 25 000 feet 250 220 pounds going
120 miles an hour with 200 feet at the
bottom that was willing to do it can you
can you kind of take a couple minutes
and walk us through the entire process
i know you said felix called you you
said yes you signed the nda
you kind of went through the process of
that but then what happened from there
the day of talking to family preparation
concerns fears walk us through a little
bit yeah no problem first off when you
say like i'm the only person who's done
it
this is true uh travis pastrana jumped
out
without a parachute but clipped into
somebody you know they've all landed
with the parachute this was the first
time doing it
without a without a parachute without
anything and coming all the way to the
net
um and i think that what that shows that
nobody has attempted it
it's interesting because from my
skydiver friends my peers i would say
my equals in skydiving um the respect
that you get and like some people say
it's crazy it's stupid why would you do
it
but to a person every single person's
come back to me
um saying that that moment that you step
out and that commitment and the
self-confidence to be able to make
something like that happen
is something that just doesn't come
along and i think that
doing it once i'm done you know i did it
one time that's good
and i think people really realized how
serious that was
but um going back to i get the call hey
can you do this how can we do it they
had an idea of a giant slide
landing on a giant half pipe in like the
grand canyon sliding it out
theoretically that makes sense to me you
match the wall with your body and you
come down you touch the wall and you
slide out like a big skateboard ramp i
just couldn't figure out how can you
test that
can you drop something in that net and
make it swoop out again i got a wife and
a son
and i want to be here to talk about it
you know i wanted to see
is there a way i could do this yeah it's
not the flip of a coin i really worked
hard to make sure that yes
i'm the crazy guy that jumped out of
playing without a parachute but i also
wanted to show that you could do
something that seems impossible
if you go about it the right way we made
baby steps so
came up with the netting idea to land in
a giant almost like a circus net
um really strong netting then um to slow
it down we used air cylinders big
pistons
so when you hit the net it compressed
the air and it
pulled it out there was talk about
bungee cords and
all different kinds of things but the
only thing i could picture is wiley
coyote
getting a net and shooting back up
so we end up with this air system in
this net and then we want to know hey
can this work
you know like i want to see is this even
possible so we built a
half scale model um in a friend's yard
jim churchman the stunt coordinator down
in california we started dropping uh
punching bags filled with weights
into this net and measuring the g-forces
and we start to figure out wow we can
actually do this
so then we built a full-scale one a 100
feet by 100 feet
we took it out in the middle of the
desert we took a helicopter aaron
fitzgerald flies this dummy
up we called it a dummy um it was this
weight that matched my weight in the
same drag
and we started dropping it in the net
from lower and lower my wife and son
come out to watch and we're measuring
the g-forces and they
come out to check it out the very first
drop they take this thing up in the air
and they drop it it cuts through the net
like butter and smashes into the ground
right in front of my wife and son camera
crews are all
film documentary they all turn to my
wife right right away
and my wife has a big smile on her face
and they're like oh luke you know what's
going on this is over
we haven't even gotten started they're
all think it's over and my wife
looked at me and the cameras and she
said well i
think it's great because now it's not
happening you know we're not doing this
thing
so for her she really didn't want it to
happen uh
it wasn't so much she didn't want to
happen it was just she understands the
reality of how dangerous she got it
yeah when that didn't work she knows i'm
not gonna do it if that's how it works
so in her mind okay this is done we're
not doing this thing we're gonna collect
a little paycheck and hang out and
that's that uh and then as the testing
started coming along
and we started we fixed the netting we
fixed the problem with how it ended up
going through the net
we get everything sorted out and then it
all starts to hit home and starts to get
real that you know
we're doing this you know and that's
when my wife and i
have some real talks about the
possibilities that could come from this
you know we went into this with our eyes
open
we definitely were not uh everything's
rosy and there's no way anything bad can
happen
i think that the guys that go into big
stunts like this with that attitude
where nothing can happen to me
i think that they're naive and
irresponsible you know
we are taking a risk when you step off
and do something like that
now i've stacked the deck in my favor
we've calculated it it's calculated risk
it's not flip of a coin fingers crossed
maybe it'll work
it was very dialed in that we were
certain it was going to work i just had
to do my job
and hit that net that day and you know
we had those
long talks with the wife it was a real
deal
and and what was that kind of what was
that like because i mean i can only
imagine the conversations are you sure
you want to do this i mean you know we
have a life ahead of us
you know what what if something goes
wrong what were those talks like
so you know before we went down to
california it was like yeah it's getting
closer it's getting real
we finally got permission to do this
without a parachute to wear it to not to
wear a parachute from the fa
and then for me that was the day it got
real for me i always thought
someone's going to step in luke and stop
this right we announce it on fox this is
happening live
i'm sure i'm confident but i'm confident
somebody is going to stop
step in and say hey whoa whoa pump the
brakes you can't do this
especially not live on tv uh and we get
a letter
saying not that we support it from the
faa but
we see that you've found a essentially a
loophole in the rules
and there's nothing that we could do to
stop this and at that moment on i was
like whoa
it got very real for me um and so
i was in the mindset of it happening on
our way to california my wife got very
quiet we flew our own little private
cessna down
it's a very quiet on the plane ride a
couple days in and then we're out at the
site
and she's watching and seeing everything
goes and i woke up two days before the
jump i walked out onto the beach
um and we're staying a little beach
house there in oxnard it's a friend's
house
and she goes hey can i go out with you i
was like sure our son was sleeping
we walked out on the beach and we sat
there it's probably i almost get
emotional talking about now it's
probably one of the
best talks that we've ever had in our
whole relationship i've been married 19
years
and i asked her flat out i said you know
where's logan going to be
where's our son going to be when the
jump happens and she had
a different answer than i expected i i
wanted him to be with her
and all that and she said logan's going
to be with my mom
i want to be as close to the net as
possible if something happens
i have the rest of my life to be with
our son but i have only that moment with
you
which is like i mean that's a real that
answer i was not expecting
wow she'd obviously put a lot of thought
into this you know
we talked about it and she had she's
very practical and she had thoughts of
well if something happens
how do we get this airplane home that we
flew down in what logistically has to
happen she's very
i think that's the way she helped deal
with it was thinking very clinically
about
those kind of things but you know we
went in with our eyes
fully open to the possibilities now we
had that talk
after that we took a nice deep breath
and you know everything moved forward
just like it planned
we did have power at that jump that
nobody knew she
had she had a radio um to talk to the
pilot in the airplane the pilot was a
lifelong friend
if she had any bad feelings anything she
didn't like
she was going to call up to dave and
tell say hey dave monica
dave was going to wiggle the tail of the
airplane and i would have sat down and
not jumped
and like i said that would have been
almost harder than actually jumping but
she had all of that control right up
right up until we went
who knew that only you dave and monica
knew that nobody else knew
that's correct nobody wow she had a
radio that would talk to him and
it was kind of our little thing i said
if you get any feelings you don't like
something you're not happy
you know this is about us and our family
it's about me obviously
i'm the greedy one that wants to jump
out play without a parachute she
wouldn't choose to do that but
you know we are a family and we got to
go do this together
what a cool story did you have any
conversations with logan as well did he
kind of know what's going on and what
was his reaction
so logan was four at the time okay he
understands skydiving he's been around
and he's seen his whole life
uh he did ask me there was talk in the
beginning whether i was gonna use this
net or an airbag and it went back and
forth back and forth and he heard
the conversations and my wife was
involved listening and
one night i was put in a bed he goes hey
dad are you going to use an airbag or a
net
what are you going to use it he was four
and i said
i don't know logan which everyone's
safer and he said well what if neither
one are safe i said then we won't do it
and he's like okay and he goes back to
his legos you know i mean that's a kid
yeah right he's like okay dad says he's
only gonna do if it's safe
that's it you know so when i look back
on it and i know he was sitting there
when i did the jump and
nowadays i think that's crazy looking
back thinking you know my son was
sitting right there and
you know you're you're throwing it all
out there yeah
i mean i saw that when for i think the
first guy came out he gave you a high
five
then your wife gave you a big hug and
you saw everybody else that was there
when you landed
uh the jump so you said something you
said
when you when you met with the seattle
seahawks psychologist
mike gervais he told you that every time
somebody's about to face something big
two weeks before the event they have a
moment
where it's kind of like you're almost
second uh guessing yourself
did you have that moment privately
yourself or no yeah and so
mike gervais such a cool dude he helped
a felix bomb gardener
jump from the edge of space he was there
help him get over some mental
claustrophobia some stuff like that
and mike i knew him then he came in to
just you know
put a little sanity in this thing right
you're jumping out play without a
parachute
and he had a couple good points he asked
me i'm a big sports guy he said luke
i've worked with a couple
big nfl teams and done this stuff how
are you going to approach this jump
is this the biggest jump of your life or
is this just another jump
he said neither one of them is wrong way
to approach it it's just a
different mindset is this the biggest
thing you're ever gonna do
or is this the just another day
and i told him in that moment right then
i said mike this is the biggest jump i'm
ever gonna do
he thought for me goes okay and we
started to approach it like that
that night i went to sleep and i called
him back the next day
i called mike and i said you know what
this is just another jump
i need to treat this just like another
jump and he said that's great that's the
way he
figured i would be thinking but so mike
worked with me with that and he said to
me
at some point you're gonna have these
thoughts about hey what are you what are
you doing why would you do this you know
those kind of things he said it usually
he thought it would happen before two
weeks
um and really i didn't have that moment
until i was about halfway up on the
airplane
on game day right i'm riding up in the
plane about halfway up you have an
oxygen mask on and you just hear
yourself breathing like darth vader
right there's you're all alone you can't
talk because everyone has the oxygen on
and i started thinking i had flashbacks
of my son and my wife and like hey why
am i doing this you know what i mean
like
yeah i think i got this i think
everything's gonna work out great but
what if it doesn't then why would i want
to do something like this
put all of this at risk i've built this
life for myself and
why would you risk that and in that
moment in the plane
my cousin andy was jumping with me he
was one of the guys wearing a camera
he was also taking the oxygen system
from me and he reaches over and he gives
me a
charlie horse on my right thigh punches
my leg
points his altimeter and goes like this
like calm down you got a second
it's that non-verbal communication that
we had he's got five thousand jumps with
me
in that moment it shook it off and i
only thought about the jump from that
moment on
moving forward that was that moment in
my mind and
mike thought it would happen way before
way before i was about to jump but
but i had that that feeling for sure
that that's that's great to have
somebody like to prepare you whether
this is going to be the
biggest event of your life or it's going
to be one of the events did he explain
to you why
either matter in preparation did he
break that down or no
a little bit uh what he he didn't want
to direct me he's very very
mike is top now he's world class he
doesn't really
tell you what like i always want to
answer a guy like that a psychiatrist i
want to answer correctly right i'm
looking for the right answer like
he says hey what are you i want him to
tell me what i should be feeling
right and he's pretty good at keeping
you you know making those decisions
um and i will say that when we started
talking about the
biggest jump of my life i think that's a
different preparation you're like
this is the biggest it psychs you up you
know you have to get to a different
energy level right
super bowl you're coming up charging
yeah um or do you want to be
my personal peak performance is not at a
10.
it's about a seven or a five and a half
to a seven
is where i personally can focus you're
not over amped on the world
and all these outside forces you can
focus but you are jacked up for the
moment
so there is a difference in how you
would prepare for something like this
there's a reason why he is who he is so
i wonder you know why he
felt uh said that whether it's the
biggest or not uh if it was a method
for him to uh uh alleviate some of the
pressure of you
but going back to the jump so your your
uh your friend i think you said your
cousin or somebody who's got 5 000 jumps
with you he punches you gives you a
charlie horse
and you're about to jump so then you
jump out okay
when you jump out the jump is what two
minutes and 39 seconds i don't know if
it's two minutes and 30 seconds or
something like it's about
two minutes or six seconds till i hit
okay oh so you hit the net okay
so it's two minutes and six seconds when
you're hitting the net so
you're going down when you're all the
way at the top and you jumped i saw the
video
i ca i can't even tell where you're
landing it's tiny
it was so small it's uh you can see the
area you can't see the net
but you see the area you're headed so
you can start heading that direction
uh and then about halfway down you
really start to pick out the pieces but
it's no joke i mean when i jumped out
you couldn't make out the net you could
make out the area where the net was
you're in the right area but you really
can't see it
and and while you're going i'm assuming
that when you do this 20 000 times you
kind of have a
way of moving your body and maneuvering
so you kind of know how to center
yourself
how hard is that to do with all the wind
with movements everything going on
so that was the second biggest thing
right we figured out how to make the net
we knew the net would work we dropped
these dummies in there measured the
g-forces
jim churchman had dialed in we knew if i
hit the net i'm good
but the biggest thing about this is
hitting that net imagine being in a
river
or out in the ocean you go out in the
ocean and you hit the tide and it starts
to
slide you down the beach a little bit
right if you want to always stay in the
same spot on the beach you have to swim
forward the tide gets stronger you have
to swim faster less you swim slower
same with the wind but the wind's coming
from all different directions
as you jump out you have to start
maneuvering your body
forward sometimes you're in this big
forward movement but that's because the
wind is going
40 miles an hour so that means you have
to go 40 miles an hour forward to be
able to go straight down
so you have to manipulate that all the
way down i had some lights that helped
guide me in
but you're fighting that all the way
down right fighting the wind and
working your way in and getting closer
and closer and that took a lot of jumps
i did
i mean i have over 20 000 jumps i did
about 350 jumps getting ready for this
and i did 70 uh my wife and i deal 75
jumps in a row
opening my parachute below 1000 feet
right above the top of the net
so that's scary about itself opening
below a thousand feet so i did
75 in a row opening my parachute
directly over the center
and from a thousand feet to the net
would it be about three seconds by the
time you would fall
and nothing's gonna grab you and throw
you off for three seconds
so we did that over and over by the time
we did the real jump which was my worst
approach by the way the real deal
um ended up i did 82 times in a row by
the time we did it for real
you can't throw a piece of garbage in a
trash can 82 times in a row
82 times in a row yeah
so so you land i saw when you landed you
didn't move for about eight seconds nine
seconds and then you started kicking you
know you were all excited when you're
kicking
and then you're on the ground you give
the high five your wife gives you a hug
everybody's coming celebrating with you
how you feeling at that moment so when i
hit the net
like that's another thing that mike told
me he's like when when you land and this
is all good
take a minute take a second and just
take it in and in that moment i'm not an
emotional guy i'm not into the
touchy-feely nonsense
uh i'm more tough it out rub some dirt
on it and get going
um in that moment i put my hands over my
head like this and it was just kind of
overwhelming all that work all that
preparation and i did it
you know and it just took a second then
i started celebrating and the best thing
is that high five you see when i first
hit the net
that was my medical exam that was the
doc
i told him i'm like hey i'm either going
to be okay or it's not going to matter
you know but that was my medical
examination
i mean what's he going to do if you
don't make it right i mean
kind of my point but the uh i was
honestly felt this like vibrating like
feeling of the whole thing and i gotta
say i wasn't so much i liked
mike trevay as a dude like a really
great guy i didn't really
get in the beginning the value that
someone like that brings to someone like
me
um i didn't really i'm like i'm well
adjusted blah blah but
the stuff by the time up until about two
weeks prior to the jump
i could visualize myself hitting the net
making contact with the net but nothing
after that right i couldn't see past
that
and about two weeks prior i started
thinking that i could see times like
this right i was visualizing
talking to people about it and moving on
and those kind of things
help their little steps those things i
didn't think i needed
but in the end we're huge right level
very interesting yeah for me i'm like
i'm not meditating i'm not whatever
and then mike says i got news for you
you are meditating you just don't know
it
you know the way i'm the way i think
about things is on the right up in the
plane i'm
dirt diving in my head or i'm
visualizing the the jump down and the
flip and i do it three or four times on
the way up
he's like every time you do that that is
meditation that is focus
i just don't sit there in a quiet room
by myself and
make alm noises but it's all the same
and that preparation was huge to be able
to make me
feel comfortable in the moment luke
who's the craziest
person that you least expected that you
hadn't spoken for a while
that contacted you to say
congratulations did you hear from a
high school teacher or a friend from it
was was there anybody that's like
i cannot believe you made this jump yeah
i mean
tons of high school kids you know
friends call you up and hit you up
um but for me there were a few of the
skydivers in the world that were like
my idols when i grew up as a kid right
that like craig gerard he was one of
like the world famous skydiver for me
golden knight was
world champion umpteen time's over he
made his way out to watch this jump
in person that day and like that was
such a cool
thing for me to wow i feel like that i
had made that
that jump you know somebody that i
looked up to as a skydiving you know
type of hero and they're there
and they acknowledged and appreciated
what i did that that's huge
that's cool somebody you admire that
comes now watching you perform and do
something like this
that's got to be a great feeling you
know they say
the the the biggest fear uh men have is
public speaking
you know a lot of people are frightened
of getting on stage and speaking to an
audience but historically
i don't think anyone's died from
speaking from stage i don't think that's
ever happened
now there's different stories with
people that decide to jump out of a
plane
and then there's stories of people that
want to jump without a parachute which
is a guy like you that wants to jump out
if if you don't have the level of you
know fear that people have because
you've done 20 000 jumps
what do you fear and how do you look at
public speaking yourself when you're up
there speaking to an audience of a
thousand five thousand people
so when this thing started after this
jump i went and gave some talks and
um i i used to start my talks now i'm a
little more comfortable but i used to
start my talks out by saying hey
thank you for having me but i would much
rather jump out of an airplane without a
parachute than stand up in front of you
guys and talk to you
it was that kind of of a feeling but for
me
i always have this mindset now that i
think of what's the worst thing that can
happen
right i try and tell my eight-year-old
son whether it's water skiing on the
lake or whatever
what's the worst that can happen not not
the worst thing you could possibly
imagine but what's realistically the
worst it's gonna happen you're gonna
fall and get wet
i'm gonna sit up there i'm gonna stumble
my words those five thousand people are
gonna think i'm an idiot
and i'm gonna move on with my life and
it's really not gonna have an effect on
me
um so those are the ways that i was able
to deal with those kind of fears and
i try to relate that to everything else
and now if i'm doing a jump
that seems a little bit hairball whether
it's jumping into a soccer stadium or
nfl game and it's windy or the
conditions aren't right
i look back on what i just did you know
hey i jumped out playing without a
parachute this is a piece of cake
you know no big deal that's cool that's
kind of how i i
my bracket has changed right it used to
be small and now it's huge
yeah i mean not everybody has a story to
tell like you said but when you're
getting up there telling a story people
are going crazy wanting to hear specific
stories
details of what happened so when you
worked on iron man
which iron man was it so iron man 3
uh where uh iron man air force one blows
up and iron man
scooping everybody up the barrel of
monkeys scene so i was the last guy to
get rescued
as they're coming in iron man uh robert
downey jr was like yeah here comes the
chunky monkey we got to catch him last
and they fly down and
you know grab your arm and that was a
really cool scene and that was happening
that was before this jump but it was
that was really cool to be part of
of the hollywood stunt scene and since
then i've done quite a few other
little projects did you have a did you
have interactions with robert downey or
no
no no no second unit stunt stuff you
don't oh i got it okay
yeah because you know for the last four
weeks we go through series with my kids
and i have to watch uh avengers one two
three i think we just finished uh
uh the the infinity war i think i don't
know which one what it's called where
thanos is getting all the five rings and
we now have to go to the end game
to watch it again with these kids
because they love this stuff but uh
when you said iron man uh black widow i
i
coordinated a sequence in black widow
that's going to come out with the
scarlett johansson like a skydiving
scene where there's some fighting going
on so you got to check that one out
you're in that one as well i coordinated
that one oh that's cool
that is cool i'm looking forward to that
so how was it working with david blaine
how
how was that experience david's is quite
the character man he's
here yeah he called me up he's a cool
cat
he has this idea and his vision what he
wanted to do and he
came to me and he's like luke you know
you did the craziest thing ever these
other guys are the greatest thing ever i
don't want to do the craziest thing ever
i want to do something beautiful and
amazing
and i've dreamed about this since a
little kid can you imagine grabbing some
balloons
helium balloons and floating away and i
said yeah i think every kid's imagining
it
he's like i want to do it i want to do
it for real i want to try and do it over
new york and i was like dude i'm in
let's figure it out and so uh i got to
spend
i helped teach him some skydiving we
worked on some techniques he'd come stay
here at the house i would come in the
living room
he'd be teaching my eight-year-old magic
tricks on the couch
and my eight-year-old could do david
blaine magic tricks that i don't
that's cool yeah such a such a cool dude
but he definitely
working with artists is interesting i'm
more of a practical guy
this this this and i get a plus b plus c
equals d
or whatever he has a vision right and
he's not willing to compromise like man
it'd be way easier if we could do it
like this he's like no
this is what i want and uh pretty cool
to work with different personalities
like that that know what they want
there's no
compromise he's going after it would you
put him as a qualified crazy
that wants to push the envelope and do
stuff that seems
unbelievable to the rest of us i would
totally put him in that category
the stuff that he does and that he's
done um
it blows my mind like when i'm talking
i'm like hey when you were
in the ice and when you did this like
where i was trying what was the gag what
was the trick
he's like well i was in the ice there's
no trick
it's like straight up being miserable
that amount of time
it's crazy to me the things that he's
done and what's really neat to me about
all of those things is
the world's full of craziness and all
this nonsense going on and it's so fun
to take a few minutes
away from that and just enjoy something
like floating with balloons i mean which
one of us couldn't think of it
i want to get helium and float my kid in
the yard with balloons yeah
did you do any of it when he was did you
try some as well or no was it
mainly him i played with it all but this
was about him about david doing his
thing
my job was there to support him and help
make it as safe as possible so i ended
up
project managing it running it and i
thought it was awesome a company like
youtube
steps up and you know back something
like that i mean who
i don't know how they make money on that
but the fact they were in there to help
make that happen was
awesome by the way for for your jump the
25 000 jump put out a parachute
how long did it take from ideation the
day you had to sign the nda
to the actual date july 30th execution
in 2016. what's the timeline
i think it was about a year and a half
to two years on that one
i mean they had to find uh the sponsor
you know i'm sponsored by red bull have
been for most of my career
red bull didn't do that one red bull
stepped back from that particular one
uh we pitched it to red bull i went in
there and i've been with red bull since
2005 and
helped felix with his jump done a bunch
of stuff i went into the headquarters
um and just prior a wingsuit person had
had passed away
a red bull sponsored wingsuit person and
articles came out as red bull pushing
athletes are they
you know making us do these things i'm
out there doing no matter what with or
whatever
people said you know what we'd like to
we're going to pass on this one
and i think at that moment they might
have thought it was over and then some
of these guys behind this jimmy and
chris went out and found
uh stride gum a gum stride gum mandalas
dried gum
sponsored that whole thing and then
somehow they convinced fox
to let it go live on tv like a seven
second delay i'm jumping out of a plane
without a parachute
if something happens i don't know does
the screen go black like what happens at
that point when you're locked
you're crazy to think about that fox
said yes and
a gum company sponsored the whole thing
the trust that they had in me it's like
i can never repay them enough
i mean stride stepping up and fox behind
them saying hey
we trust your ability we don't think
anything's gonna happen
it was never hey what happens if it
happens i never got those talks they
just never came that way it was all
full speed ahead which is incredible
that tells you how much they trust you
by the way luke any
next projects coming up with you are you
working on anything big anything you
want to share with the audience
yeah man i've been trying for a bunch of
years since before i did the no
parachute jump
i had this idea and it's a spin on
something i saw when i was a kid
but now since the no parachute jump
people answer my phone calls when i call
up
you get a little more you got a little
more class than the david lane thing
and all these you know you they answer
your phone calls you're not a crazy guy
anymore
um i have this idea where i want to fly
one airplane my cousin andy who was on
the big jump with me
flying another one nobody else in them
fly these planes up to 13
14 000 feet in the air all by ourselves
nobody else in formation put them in a
dive
straight at the ground jump out of each
airplane so ghost ride the airplanes
leave them empty
and switch planes i'll go get in his
plane he'll get in mine
pull him up and bring him back down and
land them come on
yeah man that's what i'm working on
what's the timeline on this uh the
timeline is finishing selling it off to
sponsors i mean
i got the planes we're pretty much ready
to go with the airplanes and
it takes a lot of research and
development and faa and what's cool
about something like this
it involves our flying i mean i got
seven eight thousand hours flying
airplanes
and twenty thousand skydives it kind of
brings every part of my life
since i was a little kid into one
stunt which is very cool for me to be
able to showcase aviation to the world
well buddy that is crazy the fact that
you're doing that and courageous let me
again i want a reminder of those two
seas man i don't want to leave one
without the other
say that again i like the second seat
yeah yeah i know you do i know you like
the second one
you got this one i can't help myself
keeps coming out i got to tell you
hey you got to be a little crazy to do
this stuff i'm not going to shy away
from that i mean
i that's why people tune in yeah i mean
when you're the only person that's ever
done something
you are in a league of your own there is
no you know there's like 58 of you
there's one person that's done this
and uh brother thank you so much for
coming out and being a guest
and just talking to us openly whether it
was the conversation with your wife
on the beach when logan was uh sleeping
to your experience with blaine and what
you're getting ready to work here we
have uh
we'll be rooting you on when that day
happens and remember this conversation
that we had here together on
valuetainment
all right thanks man thanks for having
me thanks for being a guest man take
care bye-bye
so you just heard a man that jumped out
of a plane at 25 000 feet without a
parachute on and
landed on a net which is crazy
what's the craziest thing you ever done
comment below i thought his story was
fascinating heartfelt
and at the same time if you enjoyed this
interview i think you would also enjoy
the interview i did with nick wallanda
who walks on wire rope and he's a
seventh generation
wire rope a walker which is pretty
intense when you watch this interview if
you've not seen it click over here to
watch it
and if you're not subscribed to the
channel please do so take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye